es ist ein tag in dem es vor allem um
dieses papier geht ich habe es hier
dabei der beschlussvorschlag für den
cola gipfel hier steht alles drin was
bald in deutschland gelten soll aber
diese version die wir sehen die ist
natürlich noch längst nicht final denn
heute wird verhandelt viele viele
stunden heute regen die
ministerpräsidenten cdu und spd ampel
gegen union und das erste das fast schon
die wichtigste meldung des tages das
zumindest des morgens habt ihr schon
verkündet sachsen denkt über einen
doktor noch das erste bundesland denkt
über maßnahmen nach die geimpfte und
umkämpfte gleichermaßen extrem
einschränken es gibt inzwischen noch ein
zitat von sachsens ministerpräsident
kretschmann dazu es geht um einen
unterbrecher lockdown hier sehen wir es
um die hohen infektionszahlen zu
bekämpfen brauchen wir einen harten
wellenbrecher bis zum 15 dezember und
der hammer ist natürlich philipp dabei
dass der eben für ungeimpfte aber auch
für geimpfte
ganz genau es ist natürlich wird das
maßnahmen geben die weiterhin ungelöste
stärker treffen aber dennoch ein
wellenbrecher heißt nach dem verständnis
der sächsischen landesregierung das
gastronomie einzelhandel und hotels
schließen und wenn die schließenden
schließen die für alle denn zweig
regelungen haben wir jetzt schon das
heißt wir anschließend gibt es sind alle
betroffen auch geimpfte menschen das ist
das szenario das man unbedingt vermeiden
wollte aber das rückt in sachsen jetzt
immer näher jetzt könnte man sich die
frage stellen bis zum 15 dezember wie
ist das denn überhaupt möglich weil die
epidemische lage also die rechtliche
voraussetzung für londons die läuft ja
eigentlich schon am 24 25 november aus
und das hat damit zu tun dass ist ein
eingeständnis was die ampel der union
gemacht hat die union wollte dass die
verordnung die aktuellen
landesverordnung noch gültig bleiben bis
zum 15 dezember auf basis der alten
epidemischen lage ist ein bisschen
juristisch aber im klartext heißt das
lockt uns bleiben erstmal noch bis zum
15 dezember möglich und sachsen könnte
das erste bundesland sein das diese
rechtliche möglichkeit nutzt und in
einen teil lockdown und einen
wellenbrecher lockt anhin wir eigentlich
schon alles zum 20 jahr 2020 ja das kann
sein dass wir nochmal glaubst du denn
dass andere bundesländer dem jetzt auch
folgen werden tja also in sachsen ist
die lage tatsächlich am schwersten
deshalb war es auch zu erwartender
sachsen die drastischen maßnahmen
ergreift wenn wir uns jetzt die korona
karte anschauen gibt es noch zwei
weitere länder für die das auch gut sein
könnte erstens thüring auch dort gibt es
sehr hohe zahlen auch was
hospitalisierungen angeht und natürlich
bayern das bundesland von markus söder
markus söder wollte sich eigentlich nie
die blöße gegeben und als erster die
schränken die strengsten maßnahmen
verhängen wenn er nicht gewusst hat dass
andere länder nachziehen deswegen das
wird auch ein politikum bleiben 1 noch
zu sachsen michael kretschmer spricht ja
von einem wellenbrecher er hatte gestern
die ganzen top-experten unteren unter
anderem lothar wieler zu gast die
natürlich auch alarm geschlagen haben
die ihm sozusagen die politische
entscheidung etwas vorbereitet haben
könnte man sagen aber die welle
zumindest die inzidenz fälle scheint in
sachsen gerade gebrochen zu sein
zumindest sinken die zahlen gerade
relativ rasant sachsen ist natürlich das
land mit den allerhöchsten instanzen
aber seit einigen tagen sehen wir wie
die kurve wirklich rasant nach unten
geht vielleicht wird der wellenbrecher
locker und das noch beschleunigt wir
schauen mal auf diesen tag der
entscheidung der für die bundeskanzlerin
heute morgen um 7 uhr 50 begann da ist
sie ja
bundeskanzleramt vorgefahren es wird
gemutmaßt ich das letzte mal sein dass
sie eine bund länder konferenz
veranstaltet sie wird vielleicht ein
letztes machtwort sprechen heute
jedenfalls ist es die letzte gelegenheit
für sie dazu aber der tag beginnt ja im
bundestag heute wo über die änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
abgestimmt wird wir müssen auch
livebilder aus dem bundestag vorliegen
haben da wird heute über die änderung
des infektionsschutzgesetzes abgestimmt
dass ja die ampel koalitionäre
eingebracht haben worum geht es da was
der hintergrund ganz genau lasst uns mal
einmal dem tag etwas strukturieren die
zuschauer weil das ist wirklich etwas
komplex was heute passiert also etappe
eins der bundestag die ampel bringt
heute das corona gesetz ein die änderung
des infektionsschutzgesetzes
setzte und das hat folgendes ziel die
epidemische lage also die rechtliche
grundlage für lockt uns die soll ende
des monats auslaufen und damit die
länder weiterhin maßnahmen verhängen
können bringt die ampel ein neues gesetz
ein das ist zwar nicht mehr ganz so
streng also ausgangssperren
schulschließung usw das bleibt alles
verboten auch übrigens die schließung
von gaststätten und hotels dafür sind
weitere maßnahmen möglich zb 2g oder 3g
regelungen aber auch kontakt
beschränkungen so das wird heute im
bundestag debattiert und die
wahrscheinlichkeit ist sehr hoch dass
das auch angenommen wird weil die ampel
also spd fdp grüne die haben die
mehrheit die union ist ja strikt dagegen
dass die epidemische notlager ausläuft
genau die union ist größtenteils strikt
dagegen aber es gibt einen interessanten
zufall die wirklich schicksalshaft
ausgerechnet jens spahn hat das ja
angekündigt jens spahn hat vor einem
runden gefahren dass die ampel die
epidemische notlage auslaufen lassen
will und dachte sich wenn das wohl kommt
dann kündige ich das mal als erster an
und jetzt kommt er nicht mehr von diesem
baum runter deswegen hat jens spahn auch
gestern in der unionsfraktion das haben
wir erfahren dafür geworben dass das
ampel gesetz angenommen wird von der
union obwohl die union eigentlich
größtenteils selbst dagegen ist